willkommen zur zdf heute live auch
dieser tag ist kein guter für die
ukraine die lage im osten ist und bleibt
dramatisch ist liefern sich beide seiten
erbitterte kämpfe und vor allem die
ukraine gegen eine russische über macht
und es ist ein tag der täglich neue
opfer fordert ich spreche gleich mit dem
gouverneur von lukas serie heidi er ist
mir per skype zugeschaltet und ich kann
schon sagen sind dramatische eindrücke
die wir gleich zu hören bekommen dazu
wie gesagt in wenigen minuten mehr ich
spreche auch mit dem general egon ramms
mit dem werden wir dann auch eure fragen
und sichtweisen besprechen und
thematisieren und ihr könnt ihr wie
immer stellen im chat oder unter dieser
eingeblendeten adresse zdf heute - live
at
zdf.de
verschaffen wir uns zunächst ein
überblick und das macht thomas konsum
mit den bildern des tages
ukrainische einheiten versuchen sie wie
egon jetzt zu verteidigen besser gesagt
das was von der großstadt noch übrig
blieb diese fotos entstanden gestern
es sind die neuesten videos gibt es
schon länger nicht mehr überall höchste
lebensgefahr
sie werden jetzt bleibt das epizentrum
der konfrontation im donbass sagt der
präsident
und ich
danke jedem der sich verteidigt das
schicksal unseres donbass entscheidet
sich dort ein grund für die bedeutung
der ostukrainischen stadt fällt sie
fehlt den russischen aggressoren nur
noch die stadtmusik chance dann haben
sie die gesamte region luhansk könnten
weiter vorrücken etwa nach bach mut in
die provinz ton jetzt doch noch ist sie
wären jetzt umkämpft seit vielen tagen
deswegen sagt der ukrainische
präsidentenberater haben die russen dort
ihre taktik geändert
sie hätten sich nun aus der stadt
zurückgezogen und nehmen sie aus der
ferne unter beschuss mit artillerie mit
luftangriffen das zentrum sei
menschenleer
insgesamt sagt der bürgermeister seien
aber noch 10.000 zivilisten in der stadt
eine evakuierung sei unmöglich
aber das industriegebiet sei noch unter
ukrainischer kontrolle ebenso das
chemiewerk
bei erneutem beschuss sollen dort heute
vier menschen getötet worden sein in
bunkern unter der fabrik heißt es haben
sich hunderte zivilisten in sicherheit
gebracht ausharren in lebensgefahr für
viele menschen in der nachbarstadt
lässig chance kommt das nicht in frage
ukrainische einsatzkräfte bringen sie in
sicherheit nur raus aus der stadt raus
aus der region luhansk
erholen wir uns informationen aus der
ersten hand ich habe vorhin mit dem
gouverneur von lohans beschreibt aus
sicherheitsgründen haben wir das vor
aufgezeichnet hören wir was er zu sagen
hat und gehen dann in die diskussion
serie bevor wir über strategien
frontverläufe und perspektiven reden
fangen wir vielleicht mal so an wie geht
es ihnen
es ist schwierig aber ich denke dass
überhaupt nicht daran und es ist mein
job für das ganze gebiet die
verantwortung zu tragen und deswegen
habe ich einfach das gar nicht im kopf
denkt gar nicht daran jetzt wie
schwierig das es dass sich seit fünf
monaten
meine familie nicht mehr gesehen habe es
ist halt ein krieg und wenn es zu
schwierig wird dann denke ich ein fan
die menschen an der vordersten front
direkt dort in den schützengraben setzen
wie sieht derzeit ihr tagesablauf aus
es ist
lauter
organisatorische
arbeit ich muss viel organisieren
menschen
aus der stadt heraus bringen ich muss ja
auch dafür sorgen dass humanitäre güter
in die stadt gebracht werden wir haben
und kaum noch nathan stellen wir haben
kaum noch fahrzeuge es muss alles
organisiert werden besorgt werden wir
müssen ja diese humanitäre
güter in die stadt bringen von den
lagern abholen und die transporte werden
des fc und beschossen sie wären ja
genauso beschossen wie anderer fahrzeuge
und humanitären zentren du musst ich
dafür sorgen dass hier alle 1 internet
auch angeschlossen sind wir müssen auch
unseren verteidigern auch helfen das
sind diejenigen auch grenzpolizisten das
sind auch armeeangehörige
beziehungsweise freiwilliger und die
polizeibeamten die unsere hilfe brauchen
wir müssen mit dieser person ebenfalls
mit allem notwendigen versorgen also im
wesentlichen billig dafür zuständig
dieser versuch deswegen abzusichern
präsident selensky sprach in der nacht
von einer sehr harten sehr schwierigen
schlacht wie schlimm ist es
es entspricht den tatsachen
ja die russische armee hat tatsächlich
alles in die schlacht geworfen alle
reserven zuerst hat man ja geglaubt
anfang des krieges das schiff innerhalb
von drei vier tagen eingenommen wird und
so eine kleine stadt wie er das
wird bereits seit drei vier wochen so
hartumkämpft obwohl schon des öfteren
auch in russischen massenmedien
berichte über die eroberung der stadt
cham welche möglichkeiten haben sie denn
der russischen armee möglich gegenwert
zu liefern
wir sind in erster linie in der mehr
sehr hoch motiviert ich glaube es gibt
kein besseres motiv kein höheres motiv
als die verteidigung des eigenen landes
der eigenen familie der eigenen eltern
kinder frauen das einzige
woran uns viel zur zeit ist
die arterie und zwar mit hoher
reichweite
leider ist das so dass einige
europäische länder sehr zögerlich sind
mit solchen waffenlieferungen und sie
wollen nicht verstehen dass putin es
nicht bei der ukraine belässt er kann
nur mit
gegenwehr gestoppt werden und wenn er
weiter geht dann landete auch in europa
wo mit wäre ihnen jetzt ganz aktuell
geholfen
geben sie uns dieser geschützter geben
geben sie uns die theorie der mehrfach
ein raketenwerfer
damit wir einfach die russische art
gallery unterdrücken könnte es ist damit
unsere reichweite größer wird und unsere
kämpfer an der front die werden das
schon selbst richten ist denn
sichergestellt dass der nachschub auch
überhaupt zu ihnen gelangen kann oder
wie groß ist auch die gefahr dass sie
eingekesselt werden
ich spreche jeden tag mit unseren
verteidigen sie wissen ganz genau sind
im bilde wie die frontlinie tatsächlich
verläuft und wie sie dynamische sich
verändert und sie sind bereit so lange
wie notwendig die stadt zu verteidigen
und das machen es jetzt mobil sie können
auch einige positionen verlassen um
bessere positionen zu beziehen
und wir machen alles dafür dass die
stadt nicht umzingelt wird und die
versorgung sowohl der armee als auch der
zivilisten ist stabil wie steht es um
die zivilisten wie viele sind noch dort
bei ihnen in der region in der stadt
betroffen und es heißt 10.000 sitzen
fest können sie das bestätigen
wenn wir nur die staatsraison netz
nehmen so sind von
120000 nur noch 15 in der stadt direkt
noch übrig vor ort
leider hat die russische armee der
kritischen infrastruktur objekt komplett
vernichtet es gibt weder
wasserversorgung noch gasversorgung noch
strom stromversorgung alles ist
tatsächlich komplett ruiniert und
hinzu kommt dass auch die vernichtung
von humanitären zentren die situation
ist recht kritisch
udo netz ist die eine stadt man muss
sich vor augen halten die nachbarstadt
lizenz heißt es ist die die noch
weitgehend von der iranischen armee
kontrolliert wird können sie das zum
einen bestätigen
voll und ganz folgen die stadt wird von
den organischen streitkräften
kontrolliert es gibt nicht mal in der
nähe dort gefecht denn das einzige
problem besteht darin dass die stadt
ständig von der russischen armee
beschossen wird und zwar aus größerer
entfernung und es wird ja alles zerstört
was überhaupt unter diesen beschuss
kommt was würde es bedeuten sollten
beide städte fallen und in russischer
hand gelangen
das ist halt wie im krieg
wir
führen diesen krieg mit einem größeren
land mit besseren
versorgungsmöglichkeiten mit höheren
vorräten an technik an personal und
selbstverständlich kann es passieren
dass wir entweder die eine stadt oder
die zweite stadt beide städte verlassen
müssen
dass wir dazu gezwungen werden aber
zurzeit vernichten wir nach unseren
möglichkeiten die maximale anzahl an
russischen soldaten und wir wissen dass
viele russen de auch demotiviert sind
dass sie einfach mit betrug mit list
einfach in die armee gelockt werden und
dass sie auch daran gehindert werden
zurückzutreten
da sich zurückzuziehen und wir brauchen
einfach so schnell wie möglich diese
neuen waffen aus dem westen reden wir
nochmal über diese waffen gerade in
deutschland wurde lange diskutiert wurde
viel diskutiert welche waffen man
schickt es hieß auch immer die frage
wie kompliziert dürfen diese waffen sein
muss erst das personal müssen ihre
soldaten geschult werden für diese
waffen reicht es einfach waffen zu
schicken ist ihnen damit geholfen oder
brauchen sie bestimmte typen die ihn
jetzt gerade in dieser situation helfen
solange deutschland darüber diskutiert
wie einzelne kleine probleme zu lösen
sind
seit
dieser lieferungen wir haben wir aus
polen aus tschechien aus der slowakei
und andere länder schon längst waffen
bekommen die ersten sind schon da und
unsere fachleute bei der armee sind
fähig genug um das ziemlich schnell
einzusetzen im krieg geht es auch immer
um propaganda um deutungshoheit was
sagen sie den menschen auch hier in
deutschland die ihre schilderungen in
zweifel ziehen
[Musik]
ich
verstehe nicht wirklich
was ich darauf wie man das zu deuten str
es gibt ja immer zwei seiten einer
medaille
wenn wir natürlich ja er war wieder
sagen wir kämpfen für unser land vier
verteidigern unser land dann kann man
das so und so wenden und das kann man
natürlich als propaganda auslegen aber
letztendlich
gucken sie auf russland dort wird
behauptet dass wir nazis sind dass wir
faschisten sind und dadurch begründet
auch russland ihrer invasion und ich
wette dass keiner von den russen die
hier gewesen sind und wir kämpfen hier
faschisten und nazis gesehen haben das
wäre für mich als propagandaarbeit hier
sagen ja der verteidiger unser land
wo ist da
ein gramm von propaganda das würde doch
jeder machen das würden die tschechen
machen das würden die letten genauso
sehen was würden sie machen wenn sie mit
unter diesem vorwand überfahren
überfallen worden wären wir machen alles
um die in diesem krieg tatsächlich die
oberhand zu behalten letzte frage was
gibt ihnen zuversicht
das ist unserer motivation
wir haben unsere
familien hinter unseren schultern wir
haben unsere frauen unserer kinder
unserer brüder und schwestern wir wurden
überfallen nicht wir haben jemand
angegriffen und wir werden so lange da
stehen wie es notwendig sein wird
danke dass sie sich zeit genommen haben
und danke dass sie sich auch die zeit
genommen haben uns ihre sicht der dinge
nahe zu bringen danke dafür
und gerade sehen wir dass das bild weg
gegangen ist werden glück und haben sie
gehört und gesehen danke dafür nochmal
ja wie gesagt in dem moment brach die
leitung zusammen aber wir konnten das
interview zu ende führen
zugehört hat auch general egon ramms und
der ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet einen
schönen guten abend herr general idea
was haben sie haben ja geradezu gehört
vielleicht auch zwischen den zeilen
herausgehört aus diesen schilderungen
des gewandes
für nicht möchte ich mal vorstellen dass
dieser gouverneur
ein sehr
geschickt denkender und geschickt
argumentieren dort menschen bewegt sich
ja nicht nur in der lage in seinem
eigenen verantwortungsbereich weil er
bewegt sich ja durchaus auch ich sag das
mal im bereich der internationalen
politik einschließlich der rolle
deutschlands das ist schon beeindruckend
die erfahrungen der letzten wochen in
der ukraine krieg haben gezeigt dass die
informationen die von der ukrainischen
seite kommen durchaus zuverlässiger sind
als die informationen die beispielsweise
die liefern und von daher ist seine
äußerungen mal in großem maß glauben zu
schenken dass die eine feststellung die
zweite vorstellung ist schon sehr
interessant
dass sich durch die argumentation der
ukrainischen offiziellen im prinzip wie
ein roter faden durchzieht das thema der
unterstützung für schwere waffen dass
der eine teil dabei aber auch
gleichzeitig die aussage dass
deutschland mit diesen entscheidungen
mit der lieferung von waffen zu langsam
ist
kommen direkt zu vielleicht nur eine
frage dazu man hört aber auch aus dass
die lage schon dramatisch ist wenn er
derart betont dass mut und vaterland
liebe sozusagen das ist womit der gegen
die russische armee kämpft
aber er steht ganz geht das ist doch das
was uns alle mit beginn des und kleine
krieges 24 februar über ausstattung auch
bei den kämpfen um kirchenvorstand der
verteidigung ist wisse der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und der verteidigungs wille
und die kampfmoral der ukrainischen
soldaten ist das was bisher im
verhältnis zum russischen streitkräften
den unterschied macht weil sein
ausgesprochen wichtiger faktor der hier
eine ganz entscheidende rolle spielt zur
lage dort zwar und flüssig chance die
lage sieht in meinen augen nicht gut aus
und er hat das glaube ich auch sehr
zutreffend beschrieben er hat auch
beschrieben was die ukrainer sich hier
ich sag das mal bewegen um lokal und
örtliche vorteile zu pflegen aber wir
müssen halt eben auch vorstellen und das
hat er mehrfach betont dass die
russische feuerwehr die die russen
nutzen um ihre angriffe auf dem boden
entsprechend vorzubereiten bestehend aus
geschützten kanonen witzen und raketen
darf an den ukrainer halt eben die
größten schwierigkeiten bedeutet das hat
ja auch einen nebeneffekt aber einen
wichtigen nebeneffekt das ist der effekt
ist in der tat was die tatsache dass
dadurch wahnsinnig viel infrastruktur in
der ukraine in diesem fall in diesen
beiden genannten städten zerstört wird
und auf diese art und weise halt eben
auch die an diese verdachts der
russische streitkräfte so vorbereitet
werden dass der widerstand für die
ukrainische soldaten im prinzip immer
schwieriger sind sie sprachen vorhin die
deutsche zögerlichkeit annehmen wir die
kommentare aus youtube und facebook noch
dazu simon kürze hat geschrieben und ich
denke das sind zwei dies gut auf einen
punkt bringen einerseits so sehr die
ukraine auch im recht ist sie werden
diesen krieg nie gewinnen können
waffenlieferungen verlängern nur das
leid und erhöhen die brutalität dieses
krieges und andererseits schreibt jemand
mit dem kürzel s p nur zögerlichen
lieferungen führen zu mehr toten wenn
schneller mehr geliefert würde würde
putin schneller zu verhandlungen
gezwungen das sind glaube ich die beiden
sichtweisen zwischen denen man gerade
sich bewegt
sondern interessante zusammenstellung
die sie gerade gewählt haben einfach aus
dem grunde weil ich persönlich der
auffassung bin dass die freiheit der
demokratische staaten europas derzeit in
der ukraine verteidigt wird das heißt
wenn jemand sagt machten die frauen zu
verlängern so den krieg sagt dass damit
in direkter weise aus der ukraine soll
auf geben und dann werden wir sehen wie
die folgen aussehen die dadurch
entstehen dann geht es weiter nach
transnistrien dann geht es weiter nach
moldau dann bekommt möglicherweise lust
darauf worauf andere an andere stellen
in europa anzugreifen von daher dass
diese lösung für mich keine lösung
sondern es tatsächlich die aufgabe und
damit würden die positiven und seiner
politik in jeder beziehung recht geben
da ist die andere auffassung die
geäußert worden ist
sagt waffenlieferung schnellstens
durchgeführt werden muss es wissen und
ich bin mal das beispiel der norweger
aus den jüngsten tagen die artillerie
geschütze in die ukraine geliefert haben
ohne lange vorher darüber zu reden aber
die geschützte sind bereits da das halte
ich dann für die bessere lösung und wir
müssen wirklich aus der zeitachse gucken
wir gehen glaube ich morgen den unis
fünften tag dieses krieges rein und wir
hätten eigentlich vor 90 tagen
entscheiden sollten die waffen zu
liefern dann wären sie schon da und die
42-tägige ausbildung für die afghanische
soldaten an der panzerhaubitze
2000 lehrer seit 50 jahren abgeschlossen
marcel das sind dimensionen über die man
sich klar werden muss und die eine
wahnsinnige rolle in der weiteren
unterstützung der ukraine spielen und
wir müssen uns darüber im klaren sein
erstes dieser konflikt ist nicht heute
oder morgen zu ende soll er wird monate
oder länger dauern ist die erste
feststellung die zweite fiktiven wie die
lokalen nicht unterstützen was über
keines verloren und wir haben es gehört
es geht ja wirklich um tage und es geht
momentan um ein stellungskrieg so muss
man es wohl nennen bei diesen zwillings
städten
die aussage zu treffen mit dem risiko
dabei das demokratische kräfte und
weitere zivilpersonen
ukrainische zivilisten durch die
russischen soldaten eingeschlossen
werden können machst du mal auf ski
fragt via facebook warum wir dem auf
deutschland eingeschlagen weil keine
waffen geliefert werden sind wir die
einzigen die so was haben die eu hat
fast 30 ländern nur mal so gefragt sagen
sie ja vorhin schon ein land genannt
aber insgesamt wenn man mal auf die
waffenlieferungen wer wieviel wann
geliefert hat wie steht es da aus ihrer
sicht
also erstens ich musste jetzt ein
bisschen korrigieren norwegen gehört
nicht zur eu so nato land welches dort
unterstützt hat ich glaube aber dass
insgesamt bei den waffenlieferungen der
gouverneur hat vorhin auch einige länder
genannt aus dem unmittelbaren umfeld die
bereits geliefert haben dass wir bei den
waffenlieferungen was die
geschwindigkeit der waffenlieferung
angeht ziemlich weit hinten anstehen ob
das jetzt innenpolitische
parteipolitische gründe sind oder aus
politische gründe sind möchte ich jetzt
nicht untersuchen ich sage das in aller
deutlichkeit
das muss vielleicht zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt noch einmal aufbereitet werden
jede waffe die nicht kommt schade der
ukraine jede waffe die zu spät geliefert
wird nutzt der ukraine nicht mehr von
daher gehöre ich mir zu reden und das
sage ich in aller deutlichkeit die sagen
wir haben zeit verloren und wir müssen
sehen dass wir diese zeit zumindest in
teilen durch die unterstützung der
ukraine zurückgewinnen
kommen wir auf die strategie zu sprechen
präsident sie lenski wir haben zu einem
beitrag gehört warnt vor einem dammbruch
denn der dom bassfeld fällt dann die
ganze ukraine ist das zutreffend aus
ihrer sicht
also präsident selensky baut in dieser
situation ich sag das mal vorsichtig
sicherlich einen damm auf einen dann
auch auf um die entsprechende
unterstützung aus dem westen weiterhin
zu bekommen also wenn der don was
tatsächlich ganzfeld sprich die region
luhansk und dann jetzt ist der krieg in
der ukraine nicht zu ende er geht weiter
man konnte aus meldungen der letzten
tage konnte man entnehmen dass
beispielsweise örtliche raumgewinne im
raum saison durch die ukrainischen
soldaten erzielt worden sind und die
ukraine wird an der stelle nicht
aufgeben sondern der krieg geht weiter
und muss dann möglicherweise an anderen
stellen weiter und intensiver
fortgesetzt werden aber wir müssen uns
darüber im klaren sein dass eine
derartige fortsetzung natürlich auch
weitere zerstörungen der ukraine
bedeuten weitere hohe verluste bei den
soldaten weitere hohe verluste vor allem
aber auch beim ziel der zivilbevölkerung
und alles was da vermieden werden kann
ist positiv wenn die ukraine diese
position hält und möglicherweise zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt mit der
unterstützung der westlichen staaten
dann auch gelände zurück erzielt
verbessert sich seine strategische
situation erkennen dass einer position
der schwäche nicht in verhandlungen mit
russland eintreten oder mit wieder mit
lautem putin eintreten weil er dann
seine verhandlungsziele die er sich
selber gesetzt hat nicht erreichen wird
und das macht die sache dann deutlich
schwieriger die lage ist sowieso relativ
unübersichtlich werden von die karte mal
eingeblendet viele städte eng zusammen
da geht es dann nicht nur um
strategische ausrichtungen sondern
natürlich auch wir haben im interview
mit dem gouverneur gehört welche stadt
überhaupt eingenommen wurde und in
welcher form
diese art stellungskrieg mit den hohen
verlusten von denen sie sprachen und wir
haben noch weitere bilder die wir jetzt
an der stelle zeigen können wie kann man
das verhindern oder ist jetzt der
zeitpunkt gekommen zu sagen da muss
schluss sein an der stelle diese form
von diesen krieg ist jetzt zu dramatisch
für die zivilbevölkerung etc oder gibt
es überhaupt irgendjemand der darauf
rücksicht nimmt
stefanski was wir sagen ist nach meinem
kenntnisstand und so wie ich die lage
einschätze in den ohren von wladimir
putin und damit auch der handelnden
russischen militärs ich sag das mal
vorsichtig völlig uninteressant
wir müssen versuchen hier tatsachen zu
schaffen dh die russen anzuhalten und
der gouverneur hat gerade sehr gute
argumente dazu gebracht die ich auch
wirklich nur noch mal verstärken kann er
sprach von der weit reichenden etui wir
müssen versuchen zu verhindern dass die
russische artillerie die russen mit
ihren raketenwerfern weit in das land
hinein schließen können
hohe verluste bei der bevölkerung an der
infrastruktur verursachen und das kann
man nur dann die ukraine nur dann
erreichen wenn sie mit dem zur verfügung
gestellten waffensystem in der lage ist
die stellung der russischen artillerie
zu bekämpfen und damit im prinzip den
beschuss von der seite von der
russischen seite her zu beenden das
heißt es geht darum die abstellung der
russen sei es sitzen kanonen oder
raketenwerfer aufzuklären und in diese
stellung hinein zu feiern so dass die
russen gezwungen werden sich aus diese
stellung zurückzuziehen oder mit
präzisionswaffen wie beispielsweise das
sonst aber bis zu 2000 raketenwerfer ist
auch dem den die amerikaner lee fand
dafür zu sorgen dass diese abläufe auf
große entfernung vernichtet das ist dann
wird sich dieses kriegs bild ändern und
dann möglicherweise so hoffe ich
jedenfalls zum vorteil der ukraine
ausschlagen wobei ich dann auch wieder
die kampfmoral der ukrainischen soldaten
bezogen möchte die wirklich
hervorragendes bisher geleistet haben
und sicherlich auch weiter leisten
werden glauben sie denn dass putin
zufrieden sein wird wenn er den osten
der ukraine erobert hat wenn die
russische armee die auch zum teil wie
jetzt schon im süden des landes seine
macht unter beweis gestellt hat
er steht ganz gysi fragen nicht wieder
ein bisschen nach der berühmten
glaskugel das noch mal versuchen dort in
diese richtung einfach eine trockene
analyse zu machen die trockene analyse
beginnt am 17 dezember nämlich an dem
zeitpunkt wo putin seine ziele für die
ukraine operation im prinzip bekannt
gegeben hat und wo er den westen
versucht hat unter druck zu setzen in
bestimmten bereichen einzulenken dass
eines dieser strategischen ziele ist die
einnahme der gesamten ukraine
das ablösen der derzeitigen die
ukrainische regierung die ja mit den
begriffen die faschisten und rassisten
und drogensüchtige belegt hat und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass er von
sich aus diese ziele auf gibt er sei
denn es sei denn er wird durchaus mittel
dazu gezwungen genau an der stelle
stehen wir jetzt und über diese
situation diskutieren wir wenn er eine
chance sieht weiter vor zu marschieren
sollte später kiew einzunehmen
durchzumarschieren das nach odessa ist
nach transnistrien zu bringen wenn er
diese chance sieht so etwas machen da
habe ich überhaupt aufgrund seiner
bisherigen vorgehensweise überhaupt
keine zweifel gibt es denn dann
überhaupt einen strategischen zeitpunkt
um zu verhandeln
ich habe das gerade schon mal ganz kurz
angedeutet und meiden sollten sie
brauchen militärische erfolge für die
ukrainische streitkräfte so dass putin
oder in russland zweifel auftreten ob
sie ihre eigenen strategischen ziele
oder auch operativen ziele erreichen
bringt erst dann machen verhandlungen
sind aus einer position der schwäche in
einer verhandlung reinzugehen ist in
meinen augen unzweckmäßig wir würden
dann aus einer position der schwäche in
verhandlung reingehen zu einer situation
kommen die dann das was der
bundeskanzler ein diktat frieden genannt
hat für die russen möglicherweise
ermöglichen würden und das kann nicht
unser interesse soll jenseits der
glaskugel wer ist denn derjenige der aus
ihrer sicht dem teufelskreis in dem wir
momentan sind durchbrechen kann und wie
letztendlich putin selber putin muss auf
irgendeine weise zu der erkenntnis
gebracht werden dass er keine keine
militärische folge mehr ringen kann das
damit seine strategischen ziele in frage
gestellt werden und ich das muss ich
auch schon wieder von hoffnung reden und
ich hoffe dass dann in der ukraine in
den russischen gehirn auch bei putin
silber ein denkprozess
einsetzt hat möglicherweise zu dem
ergebnis kommen könnte das alles was
danach kommt dann für die russen eine
verschlechterung bedeuten würde und dann
könnte man vielleicht darüber die
bereitschaft erreichen sich an den
verhandlungstisch zu rechnen zu setzen
wir sollten vielleicht auch im westen
nicht so viel über verhandlungen reden
so dass vielleicht mehr entschlossenheit
zeigen diesen krieg weiter zu
unterstützen zugunsten der ukraine denn
schon das signalisieren von
verhandlungsbereitschaft wird seitens
putin das zeigt die geschichte der
letzten monate der letzten wochen als
westliche schwäche ausgelegt und wenn er
auf diese art und weise auch wegen
unterschiedlicher politischer äußerungen
beispielsweise der europäischen staaten
in der lage ist einen keil zwischen die
europäer zu treiben dann hat er den
ersten schritt gemacht und praktisch zum
eigenen erfolg zu kommen das ist etwas
was wir nicht zulassen dürfen wir reden
über ein land ein selbstständiges land
mit eigenem territorium das geht so
nicht weiter
befragt wie youtube rams wie definieren
sie denn die kriegsziele der ukraine
also wenn mein kenntnisstand richtig ist
obwohl es ja auch sehr unterschiedliche
nachrichten gegeben hat mal hat man sie
lenski zugesagt da würde sich dann wenn
der donnersberg wäre und die krim weg
wäre damit zufrieden geben wenn ich die
information der letzten tage detailliert
und genau bewertet da hat die ukraine
die absicht die integrität ihres
territoriums so wieder herzustellen wie
sie vor 2014 vor der annektierung der
krim gewesen ist und das ist auch ein
legitimes kriegsziel für die ukraine und
damit auch für den präsidenten so lenski
und ich wiederhole meine aussage und
dabei sollten wir die ukraine
unterstützen die freiheit europas wird
in der ukraine verteidigt darüber müssen
wir uns im klaren sollen
abschließend es macht einen unterschied
ob man sagt die ukraine darf den krieg
nicht verlieren oder sie muss ihn
gewinnen die politik hat ihre sicht der
dinge welche haben sie
also ich glaube war der aussage die ich
gerade gemacht habe unsere unterstützung
muss dahin gehen dass das zumindest der
erste schritt dass wir die ukraine so
stark befähige mit unserer unterstützung
die auch lange dauern kann laut lange
dauern wird das für die ukraine
befähigen erfolge in diesen in dieser
schlacht in diesem kampf zu haben die
möglicherweise herrn putin zum
nachdenken bringen das ist der erste
schritt sollte er darauf nicht reagieren
kann das ziel auch von unserer seite her
nur sein die ukraine durch den
entsprechenden einsatz der ukrainischen
soldaten mit unserer unterstützung zu
befähigen dass sie ihre territorialen
grenzen von vor annektierung der krim
wiederherstellen können
abschließend vielleicht noch ein
kompliment an sie von claire die via
youtube schreibt danke für diese klaren
worte auch das gebe ich mal nach
herstelle weiter und bedanke mich für
die zeit und für ihre aussagen und
verabschiede mich dann auch an dieser
stelle das war heute live für diesen tag
mit einem weiteren tag der ich sagte das
eingangs nicht gut für die ukraine läuft
aber eine an dem wir auch wieder neue
sichten und weisheiten sozusagen aus
erster hand bekommen haben einsichten
nennen wir es so
in diesem sinne euch einen schönen abend
und bis bald